ein Hauch von Wehmut damals in Berlin
großer Zapfenstreich höchste
militärische Ehren für Angela Merkel
nach einer Amtszeit von 16 Jahren
sie haben mich politisch und menschlich
gefordert und zugleich haben sie mich
immer auch erfüllt morgen bekommt sie
den höchsten deutschen Orden das
Großkreuz des bundesverdienstordens mit
Stern und Schulterband in besonderer
Ausführung eine Auszeichnung die bisher
nur Helmut Kohl zu Teil wurde und vor
ihm Konrad Adenauer
zu viel der Ehre sagen Kritiker wenn
Frank Walter Steinmeier seiner alten
Chefin diesen Orden verleiht beweist er
nicht nur Angela Merkel und die Probleme
ihrer Ära sondern auch sich selbst und
ich glaube das ist ein Akt der
verantwortungslosen Ignoranz der der
Glaubwürdigkeit der Demokratie schadet
Probleme ihrer Ära damit ist auch ihre
Außenpolitik gemeint verglüht in den
Trümmern ukrainischer Städte viel zu
lange habe Merkel den Worten Putins
vertraut nicht nur in Minsk kritisiert
Röder selbst CDU-Mitglied das ist in der
Tat ein kapitaler außenpolitischer
Fehler gewesen vor dessen Scherben die
deutsche Politik heute steht Minz hat
verhindert über Jahre das ist zum
Ausbruch des Krieges gekommen ist
übrigens steht die Ukraine heute
werfähig da was sie 2014 gar nicht
gewesen wäre nur wenige treten so wie
Armin Laschet für Merkel in die Bresche
bei der CDU vielstimmige Schweigen keine
Kritik aber eben auch kein Lob und
getreue die um gute Worte Ringen wirken
etwas bemüht sie ist immer die Patente
Frau geblieben als die sie ganz jung
1990 daran werde ich mich immer lebhaft
erinnern beim vereinigungsparteitag der
CDU
für viele überraschen zu
stellvertretenden Parteivorsitzenden
gewählt wurde das Schweigen rührt
vielleicht auch von einer Energiepolitik
voller Widersprüche erst wollte Merkel
Atomkraft als Brückentechnologie
erhalten der Ausstieg aus dem Ausstieg
dann nach Fukushima ihre hastige
Energiewende zurück zur Kohle bis die
klimaproteste 2019 sie auch hier zum
Ausstieg zwingen Merkel als getriebene
wie 2015 in der flüchtlingskrise der
posierte sie gerne für selfies ließ sich
für humanitäre Gesten feiern auf die
Integration der Menschen aber war das
Land nicht vorbereitet ich bin erstmal
sehr zufrieden dass man Leute im Not
auch aufnehmen kann und das Deutschland
auch bereit war diese Menschen
aufzunehmen was aber Merkel ihre
Regierung und wir als Gesellschaft nicht
verstanden haben was wollen wir
eigentlich schaffen was wollen wir wie
wollen wir diese Leute erreichen auf
Kritik aber reagierte Merkel damals
genervt
Anfang uns noch entschuldigen zu müssen
dafür dass wir in Notsituationen ein
freundliches Gesicht zeigen dann ist das
nicht mein Land wenn man eine
Persönlichkeit beurteilt muss man das
aus dem jeweiligen Moment tun und nicht
im Nachhinein alles besser wissen
aber es geht ja doch um einen Orden den
höchst zu mal und die Kritik wurzelt
sehr viel tiefer
Angela Merkels Politik der
Alternativlosigkeit hat eine Entwicklung
der demokratischen Kultur in Deutschland
befördert in der nicht mehr die Vielfalt
der unterschiedlichen Meinungen zählt
die in einem Wettstreit miteinander
stehen sondern indem es nur noch die
eine Wahrheit gibt nämlich die eigene
auf Merkels Schreibtisch im Kanzleramt
stand eine Zeit lang ein kleines Porträt
die russische Zarin Katharina die Große
deren Kanzler hieß potientkin der
Legende nach der Erfinder der
potent-kitischen Dörfer ein Schelm wer
böses dabei denken